man it's incredible humans are humans
it's incredible like [ __ ] man I really
just wish people just wanted to like
each other all the time we can have so
much fun
we could have so much [ __ ] fun socks
we can have so much fun
[Music]
coming to you live from Sydney Australia
you've checkout browse got that Opera
House right out there like what that
iconic building on my way to Melbourne
right now gonna rip some [ __ ]
Australian faces off I'm spending a lot
of time on mindset I don't like mindset
because it feels fluffy it feels a
little too motivational speaker and I
don't love it but the truth is it
[ __ ] matters because the reason that
matters is because it's the way you
basically approach everything you know
one of the biggest reasons I think I've
been able to build good companies is I
put an enormous stress on leaders
managers of mine to understand that
they're not capable if they are not
capable of being the bigger woman and
man in every situation even if they are
100 percent right they don't have the
framework to be successful as a leader
this whole process real closely and I've
just been really looking forward to
connecting
and if he chooses to because I don't
want to force anybody do anything the
you know down times in his career to
build relationships and infrastructure
that lasts him for the 50 70 years he
lives after football
hey Gary babban I'm Helena I just met
you at Sydney Airport very briefly
before you guys got on your flight to
Melbourne and I sat on that flight so
hyped that I run into you guys and then
I got home and opened Facebook and so
two years ago to this day was the first
time I saw any of your content and it
was just before launching my own brand
and I need to say thank you for giving
me the confidence and bravado to just be
like [ __ ] it just one showing off to New
York after yeah yep in and out what are
you going over I've been here three
times on business in the past when I
grew up in the wine world yeah I know
the people are [ __ ] awesome and I
know that there's good solid hustle I'm
negative to you is crazy to me
insecurity at its finest
just so stupid
why would you be mad you should be happy
so motivate you I love seeing people win
Chris Sacca like crushing the investment
game like during my era which mean pop
he deserves it he was right about
Twitter bought up all the secondary it
was right about Luber earlier [ __ ] it's
right about Instagram like why would I
be upset you know I love it raise the
bar for all you know what the best part
is it's like when you can get to that
mindset when you loved winning but the
only thing that you love more than
winning is losing then you're [ __ ]
dangerous when you're just [ __ ] you've
won the head before you've started
I love losing like 11 nothing in like a
one-on-one game as long as I know
there's more games to be had like like a
piano like a VJ beats me 11 nothing and
the first I'm like Bob I'm like this is
perfect you know I don't know I just
don't get people I just don't understand
is such a flaw in stopping you from
getting to where you want to get to
you're putting out negative energy or
you're spending mine you know you're
spending energy and time other people
that are winning we're gonna win
regardless of what you think
winners win quicker you wrap your head
around that the more you don't spend any
time on them and you move on and you
know that's gonna be stretching goodbye
gotta give a huge shout out to
Australian hotels they've been nice as
[ __ ]
you've already been you know you've
enjoyed him I think Zac Nadler has been
a jock have you brought value to the
vlog every day okay I'm about to
completely destroy the faces of every
single person at this Melbourne talk I'm
just not even gonna be [ __ ] around
like I'm gonna go 11 instead of town
tonight it allows me to start this talk
with something I don't really talk a
whole lot about I think I once quoted it
on Instagram but other than that I'm
fascinated by people's need to justify
their ambitions instead of just focusing
on them themselves there's so much
insecurity in this system which is what
leads so many people to be fearful to
take the jumps that they want to do
because they're worried about what other
people are gonna say about their
failures and I'm fascinated by that
because no question my biggest strength
was the self-esteem that my mom put
inside of me and the environment that I
grew up with and thick skin of being an
immigrant and not having much and all
the benefits that I had
What evil Franco better fight with
middle school
holy [ __ ] Abel Franco I'm really does
not like wait a second
God Almighty and this dude was my super
friend super friend dude this is one
microphone it that's one of my true
[ __ ] frets Abel Franco is why the
vlogs perfect Abel [ __ ] Franco the
best Abel what you don't remember and
you remembered first of all it's
terrible to hear what happened to your
mom I remember your mom and I'm so so so
sorry that's ridiculous I'm emailing you
in a little bit what you don't remember
is I came over your house for Survivor
Series in sixth grade and it was the
[ __ ] best I remember everything about
it you were a tremendous WWF fan and my
court me you were the I'm trying to
think of there was one other kid who
actually Oh Regan who died in a car
accident high school I moved away as
well so did you but uh I remember going
to your house and watching that Survivor
Series
like yesterday brother I'm so [ __ ]
pumped that you you just emailed me I
can't wait to reconnect a crew you know
there's you know there's not a lot of
people I fully remember either from
middle school back in the day and Edison
but you're one of them brother I'm so
happy right now I can't wait to connect
is that literally you may make one make
sure he makes like if it whatever story
tell but if there's if there's not force
one hundredth of a second of a minute
you'll [ __ ] how many people will reach
out to you well you know what people
don't know they don't get more people
watch my blog then then the far majority
of cable television ships people don't
get what's actually happening they don't
understand that a cable show has 37,000
actual Watchers of their show they don't
get it so you're gonna make like a 1
second appearance like it up but like
there it is that's it that's it I
literally get email from like your
fourth grade teacher mrs. Thompson
but it's really really fascinating to me
of how people spend their energy and
their time so much of it is what I would
call defense work hedging against
justifying explaining why reacting to
the market instead of reacting to what's
going on in their own dome third speech
in Australia saving the best for last
the framework of how I attack the game
has so much more to do with the way I
feel about my intent and how I'm going
about doing it and all these warm and
fuzzy things that I tend to like to talk
about they're just strengths humility
and empathy and gratitude and all these
warm emotional intelligence pillars are
enormous strength
[Applause]
there's a huge disconnect right now with
entrepreneurship let me tell you what
entrepreneurship is it's lonely it's
stressful
it's you know difficult it sounds great
on paper until you realize when you have
employees you work for them not they
work for you so many people are built on
one pillar some arbitrage some thing
somebody's feeding them something
Facebook Google something's working but
it's a one punch pony and if you watch
fighting if you like UFC or boxing once
somebody figures out it's every sport
you can go from highlight the [ __ ]
football to bat if you have one move
when the market figures it out you're
finished and so many of the business and
so many of the people that I'm analyzing
right now have one move and they don't
realize that technology's about to take
away that move and they literally go
from hero to zero in a heartbeat my
friends it is time to get educated on
what's actually happening my friends if
you do not deeply deeply deeply
understand how to market on Facebook and
Instagram please run the [ __ ] out of
here and go to Google and spend the next
400 hours watching videos and reading
books and testing because it is
absolutely the underpriced place I don't
give a [ __ ] about Facebook or sucks like
a care less than a closed tomorrow I
care about where you spend attention and
it's underpriced and it is very crystal
clear so please take advantage of this
incredible era because if you do not
somebody else will and that's gonna come
at your detriment and the people here
that really go all-in will have it and
the people that don't will feel it and
to me that's why I want to come with
this gusto here today because to be very
honest with you I fully expect only 95%
to do nothing about it
95 you'll put your pump now this feels
good I'm shootin the [ __ ] out of my
energy directly in your [ __ ] mouth but
but next Thursday's gonna happen and you
lose a client or something gets [ __ ]
up or you got to pay some bill and then
you don't go on the offense and so I'm
hoping for three or four people to email
me in two years I get it man and I've
heard that my whole life and guess what
people are just not executing and it's
so real
you know it's so hard to believe
something's happening you know when you
don't see it when you don't feel it when
you don't see and feel what I feel I get
it because there's a lot of things in
the world that I don't see and feel and
then they happen people like I told you
that plants didn't have as much protein
as they used to have like what plants
have protein what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like I don't you know it's
a lot of [ __ ] I don't know but there's
one thing I know and I've known in my
whole life I know what you're gonna do
before you do it and that's why I get to
stand up here and I'm telling you right
the [ __ ] now Facebook and Instagram and
voice bet your [ __ ] children's health
on it
thank you I'm tired which is great we
did destroy we did [ __ ] destroy
Australia we sliced Australia grittier
we'll chat next week yeah thank you so
much hey thanks for such a wake
thanks for fun thank you cool all right
guys and you've been waiting this whole
Australian trip I know you have babban
is your first experience where a normal
businessman turns into the world's
greatest emerging superhero Airport Gary
superheroes of the 21st century
it is officially Airport Gary
[Music]